it was a book by neil gordon called the
company you keep and the book itself is
written the entire book is written
as a series of emails and the so the
adaptation was
was complicated the characters were all
there the plots were all there and then
some i mean the book is
you should read the book if you enjoyed
the movie it's there's a lot of
other sort of side plots that happen but
um
but because it was not a straightforward
narrative i think
the
actual adaptation process for us i mean
it was a long just i mean it's we read
it in 2004 and it's
2013. so
um it was a long process to sort of get
it to the place and hone it into to
focusing on the themes that we really
wanted to focus on
you know when we first read it it felt
like
a
quintessential sort of 70s robert
redford movie and he's never directed
one the themes of it speak
directly to his heart i mean it's got
family it's got
um you know diving into the gray areas
of american history which he loves to do
and loves to look back on
on historical events and and
get inside sort of the humanistic part
of it and not just look at it with sort
of the broad strokes that we often think
about with history well julie christie
obviously her personal
you know she's such an activist even to
this day and and
a bit of a recluse um which redford
really appreciates i mean she lives in
like the mountains of spain and
she's a real i mean she's such an
individual i mean she really is an
interesting character but the courting
process for julie was
the most complicated in the sense that
we center the script but it was it came
redford came up with the idea he never
worked with her they came up with the
business in the business in the same
sort of era
they have the same they share passion
for
for you know activism and and
and they both have a sort of a slight
just not disregard but but they're
they don't neither of them live here
neither of them really sort of connect
with hollywood um and so i think he
found that really attractive but we
center the script and the great thing
about julie is she's she tells you
exactly how she feels and she came back
with like a two-page handwritten letter
about why she's not really an actress
why she's wrong for the role
why she never wants to work again and
why thank you but no and so
two months later after like calling her
and courting her we finally sort of
cracked through and and we're obviously
thrilled that we did but it was
it was a challenge certainly um she's
you know
she's not one that uh you can't sweep
her off her feet
casting um
an 11 year old is always difficult but
we did an exhaustive you know we shot
the movie in canada
we exhausted canada we exhausted the
united states we were it was the
saturday before
um we went to cameron and she was due up
to shoot thursday
and
we had rehearsal with shia and susan on
saturday um late evening and and
afterwards we were sort of we were
wrestling with between two girls
um and sort of redford went back to his
room and we all just sort of like you
know i said we were supposed to have
made the decision on friday and of
course we didn't
and uh so redford went back to his room
and ordered room service and threw the
tv on to sort of clear his mind
and what came on was america's got
talent and the person on america's got
talent was jackie ivanko singing puccini
and he it was a close-up of her at first
and he was like he literally thought you
know he had lost his mind there's this
like incredible if you've never seen her
sing you know youtube it's amazing
but she was this angelic 11 year old who
just had this glow and this composure
and he said if she can do that
then she can act and so
he immediately called he's like we got
to find her she was in pittsburgh not an
actress we put her on tape
got the tape on monday looked at the
tape he was like i love her everyone
else is like you're crazy
he hired her there's always visa issues
we got her on the ground wednesday night
and she was in front of camera
thursday morning
opposite redford so it was a really
he basically met her while they were
shooting the movie which is kind of
amazing he is he's not the most hands-on
director anyway he loves to give actors
sort of latitude and he loves to let
them work and find their process so when
he's actually
in the scene it's not that much
different than when he's just directing
i think he
um
he's a guy who operates on instinct he's
you know he was started as a painter and
he's just been he's an artist at heart
um and he just he's very instinctual all
the presidents men is it was the the
height of journalism if you will and i
feel like we're
we're not at the height of journalism
right now and and it's uh it's a very
challenging field to be in and i think
um
there's
what's tough for journalists right now
and again i'm not i don't mean to speak
for your uh but what we wanted to depict
was what's difficult is
there's with the internet with twitter
everybody at some point is a journalist
in a way like anyone can blog anyone can
sort of put a story out there and
his character does represent that
generation but it's also a little bit of
a throwback to a guy who does the
research and does pound the pavement and
and
was inspired by the all the president's
men by the woodward and bernsteins and
and there was a lot of talk with shah
about that movie he studied that movie
that sort of tenacity of journalists it
they still exist it's just it's just
harder for them